thank you for joining us today this is
brian hall product manager of the
imaging flow cytometry instruments at
luminex corporation and i'll be joined
by katie gillis product manager of the
guava mu systems and stephanie burnell
product manager of the set of the cell
stream and together we will be reviewing
imaging and flow cytometry applications
critical to the field of immuno oncology
the amnest imaging flow cytometers are
high throughput microscopes that collect
bright field dark field and up to 10
channels of fluorescent imagery at a
rate of 5 000 objects per second this
generates a large image database that we
can then use statistical image analysis
software to go in and effectively mine
that database for unique morphologies
based not only on fluorescence intensity
but the location of that fluorescence as
well
and this enables some novel applications
that you can do with this type of
technology including cell signaling
applications co-localization apoptosis
and many others
this combination of flow cytometry and
imaging
allows researchers to gain a deeper
understanding of the subcellular
processes within their samples
it allows for a limitless number of
applications to gain a deeper
understanding it allows researchers to
make novel discoveries learn the
mechanism of actions and effectively get
the science right
in this first example we're going to
look at t cell activation after binding
to antigen presenting cells and
demonstrate nf kappa b translocation to
the nucleus
these t cells are harvested from the
thymus of transgenic mice that are
sensitive to ovipeptide where treatment
with ova
enables the t cell to bind the andengine
presenting cell
for the image stream experiment we're
going to label the t cells with cd8 the
antigen presenting cell with cd45 we're
going to label the nucleus and nf kappa
b as well and then in the analysis we're
going to be measuring the percentage of
cda positive t cells actively involved
in conjugate formation with an apc
and showing activation indicated by
translocation of nf kappa b to the
nucleus
now the first part of this experiment
begins identifying the doublets versus
the single cell population so the
population in the upper left of this
plot shows that these are the single
cells and the r3 population are the
doublets now these doublets could be
coincident conjugates or t cells
actively engaged with an antigen
presenting cell so to verify that we
have a t cell apc conjugate we're going
to look at a cd45 versus a cd8 intensity
plot
and identify
true conjugates we can verify that
population in r5 by looking at the
imagery showing one t cell and one
antigen presenting cell
now the next step of this analysis
is to identify the nucleus of the t cell
to do this we can use a mask and a mask
simply defines a region of interest
ideas has a number of different masks
that you can use to look at different
subcellular compartments
and in this example we're going to be
looking at a combined mask
for this analysis we're going to be
masking the cd45 apc and the nucleus of
both the t cell and the antigen
presenting cell
we can then overlay the cd45 mask on the
nuclear mask and remove it from
consideration in the analysis so we've
effectively masked the nucleus of just
the t cell and not the antigen
presenting cell
we then use similarity which is
effectively a measure of nuclear
localization of nf kappa b
on these true conjugates
and by looking at similarity of this new
mass that we've created we can see that
events that have a low similarity score
so that most of the nf kappa b is
sequestered to the cytoplasm
whereas after treatment with a high dose
of ovipeptide we get an increase in our
similarity or translocation score
and simultaneously the imagery
demonstrates that nf kappa b has
migrated into the nuclear compartment in
just the t cell showing t cell
activation
we can then use the similarity feature
over time in different doses
to create a dose curve and measure the
ec50 after treatment with different
other concentrations
in this next experiment we'll be looking
at how morphology can be used to measure
the cell cycle progression the apototic
index both before and after treatment
with a chemotherapeutic agent
now this is a cell line u2 os cells that
have been genetically modified using
zinc finger nucleases to add fluorescent
proteins to both the lamin b1 protein on
chromosome 5
the tubulin a1b protein on chromosome 12
and the actin b protein on chromosome 7.
the u2 os cells are effectively an
adherent cell line so to maintain the
adherent morphology these cells were
fixed on the plate and manually brought
into solution the cells were also
stained with drac 5 to label the nucleus
so that we could look at chromosome
formation and progression throughout the
cell cycle
each phase of the cell cycle can be
characterized by total dna content
and the morphology of the actin and
tubulin fluorescence coming from
the
fluorescent proteins in these cells and
as you can see from the imagery
as the cells are in g0 g1 they maintain
the the adhered
morphology
during s phase they gradually begin to
increase the amount of dna in their
nuclei
at g2 they begin to prepare for mitosis
and then in the prophase you can see the
cells begin to round up off the plate
and start to form chromosomes during
metaphase those chromosomes align on the
metaphasal plate and in anaphase you
start to see separation of the
chromosomal centers and in telophase you
can see in the bright field imagery that
the two cells are beginning to pinch off
and form daughter cells and then re
returning back to the g0 g1 phase you
can see that the cells then lay back
down onto the plate and so by capturing
an image of each of these cells in
solution
we can get a really good indication of
cell cycle progression throughout each
phase of the cell cycle
now if you look at the morphology of
these cells during mitosis you can see
that the nuclear envelope dissolves as
the cells begin to
progress through mitosis
you can see that tubulin starts to
polymerize forming mitotic spindles to
bind to the chromosomal centers and you
can see that the cytoskeletal structure
breaks down
now if you look at a total intensity
plot that measures the amount of
fluorescence coming from each of these
monomers you can see that the monomeric
form is still retained in the cytoplasm
so just looking at total intensity alone
as in figure a
is not enough to characterize the phase
of mitosis that these cells are in
that's because the monomeric form is
still in the cytoplasm and fluorescing
so the total amount of fluorescence is
the same what's really changed is the
morphology of that fluorescence so in
the plots along the bottom you can see
we can utilize morphometric features to
in the case of exam of plot b
look at
a dissolution of the
nuclear envelope
see you can see there's a dramatic
increase of this tubulin formation
morphology
and in plot d you can see that the
cytoskeletal structure dissolves
breaking down and allowing the cell to
progress through the phases of mitosis
vinblastine is a chemotherapeutic agent
used to treat hodgkin's lymphoma and it
functions by binding tubulin to prevent
proper formation of the mitotic spindle
and block cell cycle progression it also
induces apoptosis
so in this example we can look at the
morphological effects of treatment of
them blasting over time
so here we treated the u2 os cells were
treated for up to 24 hours with 0.5
micromolar then blasting the apotonic
index is measured by looking at nuclear
condensation and nuclear fragmentation
as indicated by the imagery
in the lower right hand corner you can
see using the nuclear morphology we can
calculate an apototic index where zero
hours we have a background of about
three percent of the cells are apotonic
and after 12 hours of treatment within
blasting about 21 percent of the cells
are apototic so we can use this plot to
create our apototic index and measure
that over time to really quantify the
effects of them blasting
on these
subcellular components
as measured by their their morphology
acute lymphoblastic leukemia is
characterized by an overabundance of
immature b cells
in this experiment we'll be looking at t
cells modified with a chimeric antigen
receptor that can target these cd19
positive b cells and induce cytotoxic
effects
so here crispr cast 9 was used to
enhance cultured lymphocytes to target
the cd19b cells
car t cells were also incubated with and
without icam which can be used as a
blocking agent and for the image stream
experiment we'll fix the cells we'll
label the t cells with either cd8 or cd4
and the b cells with cd19 and compare
which of the t cells either the cd8s the
cd4s or the cd84 combination does the
best job of identifying the target b
cell
we can then quantify conjugate formation
and the cytotoxic effects as well as
look at icann blocking
to analyze this experiment we want to
begin
by characterizing the t cell subsets in
this sample
so thymocytes will express either cd4
single positive t cells cd8 positive t
cells or early thymocytes
can express cd4 and cd8 simultaneously
after gating on these three different
car t subsets we can compare their
ability to bind to b cells
and induce cytotoxic effects so in the
middle series of dot plots you can see
approximately 18 percent of the cd4 cd8s
are binding to
the b cell looking at the corresponding
imagery in the top panel you can see
these cells are double positive for cd4
and 8 and they're attached to the b cell
about fourteen percent of the cd4
positive car t cells are binding to the
b cell
uh and
about seven percent of the cd8 positive
car t cells are binding to the b cell
so after compiling the data from that
analysis we can now start to compare the
effects of treatment with icam
and look at that over each subset of car
t cell
so if you look at the cd4 cd8 car t cell
that seems to show the greatest affinity
for the target b cell
if you look at the cd8 only positive car
t cell seems to have a relatively low
affinity for the b cell and clearly icam
inhibits car t binding in each of the t
cell subsets
so utilizing the image cytometry and the
imagery we can not only characterize car
t binding its target cell
we can also look at cytotoxic effects
and downtrend downstream experiments and
we can use the imagery to really
characterize the effectiveness of our
car t cells when treatment with
cancer such as al
so that was the last example that i had
showing the benefits of imaging flow
cytometry when analyzing your
immuno-oncology experiments next i'll
turn it over to katie gillis who has
some great applications that she
describes using the guava muse systems
thank you
the guava muse and guava easy site
systems have many applications for the
immuno oncology market we are now going
to discuss some of those applications
the guava news and easy site instruments
use a patented micro capillary system
that provides a simple and reliable
design
the micro capillary eliminates the need
for shea fluid in our faux cytometers
utilizing our patented fiberglass faux
cell
the laser light hits the flow cell
it allows for scanning of every particle
that flows through the system
we then combine this with a positive
displacement syringe pump
allowing us to determine absolute counts
because we know exactly how much fluid
flows through the system
every acquisition
in addition to the accurate cellular
counting the
micro capillary and syringe pump design
provides
the technology allows for small sample
sizes which preserve your precious
cellular samples and produce low
biohazardous waste
the muse and easy site technologies
provide pre-validated kits that allow
for the identification and enumeration
of both whole blood and pbmcs
these assays are mix and read and take
as little as 10 microliters of sample
the sample is mixed with one of our
pre-formulated kits and acquired on our
muse or easy site instruments
each instrument has a predefined
acquisition and analysis template that
allows the user for simplified
acquisition and analysis
the guava counting assays highlighted
here
utilize our proprietary mix of dyes to
exclude cellular debris and identify the
count
of nucleated as well as
debris
we also identify
viable dead and dying cells unlike
assays that utilize trypan blue the
guava counting assay usually uses a dna
intercalating dye that indicates any
membrane disruption and can be an in
early indication of cellular distress
the guava immunology assays are
developed to provide to provide the user
with cd4 cd8 or b cell concentrations
and the percentages of the in the
overall lymphocyte population
these are also mix and read assays that
can be combined to determine
all of the various populations
here we show data for the muse count
viability assay on pbmc samples
a simplified output for the assay is
shown
in the upper left
you can see here that
the assay provides viable cells
per ml
percent viability
total cells per ml as well as
pop dot plots for clear separation of
the various populations
the graph shown here compares
the cell concentration on the mu cell
analyzer versus a predicate method for
both fresh and frozen pbmcs
as the data shows similar performance
from the mu's count and viability assay
was seen when compared to the predicate
method
with both r squared and slope values
overnight over 0.9
additionally the table in the lower left
showcases the percent cv for replicate
measurements the percent cvs shown for
both fresh and frozen pbmcs are well
below 10
this data indicates highly precise and
accurate measurements that can be
attained while using the mu cell
analyzer for accountant viability
measurements
results for the muse immunology assays
are shown here
the muse immunology assays provide
absolute counts total lymphocyte counts
and population percentages
based on the total lymphocyte population
for either cd4 cd8 or b cells
two of the assays are highlighted here
the dot plots in the upper left
highlight the results for either the cd4
assay or the cd8 assay
the lymphocyte population is shown on
the y-axis for both plots and either the
cd4 or the cd8 population is shown in
the x-axis
very clear separation for the lymphocyte
populations is shown for both assays as
well as clear separation for the cd4 as
well as the cd8 population
a comparison of the cd4 counts for a
predicate method versus the mu cell
analyzer is shown in the graph on the
right
you can see that based on the linear
response that is shown
based on both the slope as well as the r
squared value that comparable results
are seen on both on the mu cell analyzer
lastly we evaluated the cv
results for the count the percent
lymphocyte as well as the count for the
total population
these results were compared for three
operators across three instruments
running four samples in triplicate
you can see that the cvs for all of
these populations were well below five
percent highlighting that not only the
precision within the assay but across
users and instruments is extremely
high
we took immune cell identification and
enumeration one step further on the
easytype platforms which have the
ability to evaluate up to 12 fluorescent
channels at one time
to do this we did a tab and nk analysis
using a blood control from an external
vendor
the dot plots show the gating strategy
and separation of the populations for
either the cd
check plus
sample or the cd check low sample
you can see that cd45 positive cells
were gated into a cd3 plot where we
looked at cd3 negative and cd3 positive
cells
our cd3 positive cells were then gated
into a cd4 versus cd8 plot
and our cd3 negative population was
gated into
a plot where we looked at cd19 b cells
and cd16 and 56 positive and k cells
you can see that the separation for all
of the populations are very clear very
clearly separated
for both the pod the plus as well as the
cd check glow
sample the graphs on the right
show the count
for
the various populations when compared to
the vendor specified values
the vendor lower limit is shown in red
the high limit is shown in pink and the
average value is shown in orange
the easy site results are shown in blue
as these results show for both the cd
check plus
low as well as regular samples
the vendor limits are the accounts are
well within the vendor limits
using fresh whole blood donors we then
decided to not only do a
tb and nk analysis on our samples but
also to evaluate the naive and memory
populations
shown here is an example from one such
donor
the data shows a similar gaining
strategy
as we saw on a previous slide getting
our cd45 positive cells into a three
pos into a cd3 gate where we looked at
the positive and the negative samples
and then taking our cd4 positive
cells and our cd8 positive cells in
doing a naive and memory analysis on
those
you can see that there's clear
identification of multiple important
immune cell populations from this simple
analysis utilizing only 10 microliters
of blood
one final area i would like to show
today is related to mechanism of action
studies during drug discovery
development and deployment
here we show an example of the
mitodamage assay that combines three
cellular health markers
to assess changes in mitochondrial
membrane potential apoptosis or cellular
death
this example deploys all three cell
health markers simultaneously
medicine spread detects changes in
mitochondrial membrane potential and is
shown as a downward shift in
fluorescence
indicating a loss of the membrane
potential
apoptosis is detected using an exon 5
which indicates phosphatidylserine
exposure
lastly cellular death is detected using
7ad
staining
where there's a loss of membrane
integrity integrity
the dot plots shown here show example
stainings for the assay on jerk cats
clear separation for each population is
seen
the two bar graphs show dose responses
for either a topicide
a known
topoka isomerase inhibitor or
styrosporin a known protein kinase
inhibitor
and the corresponding population
percentages
with depolarized populations shown in
red
apoptotic populations shown in yellow
yellow
and cellular death population shown in
blue the bar graph is shown for both
compound depolarization and apoptosis
see similar percentages but little
cellular death was seen additionally at
this time point sterosphorin shows a
much larger shift
in depolarization and apoptosis when
compared to atopicide therefore in
addition to counting an immune cell
subpopulation identification
the guava platforms can be used to
evaluate and assess drug mechanism of
actions and effects
thank you
now i'll turn it over to stephanie
next we'll talk about the amnes cell
stream which is based off of the same
tdi ccd technology as the image stream
and flow site which brian talked about
earlier
the cell stream system is a benchtop
camera based flow cytometer built on the
amis technology similar to the image
stream an image gallery is used to
visualize objects in flow the cell
stream is a high throughput compact
system with a small footprint and it
allows for modular and flexible upgrades
the high sensitivity of the slow
cytometer allows for traditional flow
assays as well as small particle
experimentation
the cell stream can be used for
traditional assays such as
immunophenotyping
in this particular study we performed a
16 color amino phenotyping of major
lymphocytes and myeloid subsets in human
pvmcs and whole blood
as you can see we easily resolve all
expected populations as well as
populations identified by dim markers
such as t cell subsets
the t cells were characterized into
distinct subsets including naive
effector effector memory
central memory activated and regulatory
t cells
the cell stream can be used for
traditional assays such as
immunophenotyping
in this study we performed a 16 color
immunophenotyping of major lymphocytes
and myeloid subsets in human pbmcs and
whole blood
as you can see we can easily resolve all
expected populations as well as
populations identified by dim markers
such as t cell subsets the t cells were
characterized into distinct subsets
including naive effector effector memory
central memory activated and regulatory
t cells
in this study we use the cell stream to
monitor the phosphorylation of signal
transducer and activator of
transcription or stat proteins which are
transcription factors that migrate to
the nucleus upon phosphorylation and
alter gene expression
stab proteins are known to be stimulated
by certain cytokines such as
interleukins
stats 3 5 and 6 which have been
associated with prognosis and cancer and
other malignancies were simultaneously
monitored in cd4 positive t cells in
these experiments
whole blood was stimulated with
interleukins 2 4 and 6.
red blood cells were lysed and the
remaining leukocytes were analyzed with
antibodies against phosphorylated stat
proteins specifically phosphorylated
stat 3
5 and 6. the gating strategy is shown
here for identifying cd4 positive cells
phosphor flow results show that il-4
stimulated stat6 as in the top panel and
you can see a shift in fluorescence
outlined by the box
il-2 stimulated stat 5 as seen in the
second row
and il-6 stimulated stat 3 in the third
row
on the bottom part of this slide you can
see a mix of interleukins phosphorylated
all the stats we investigated the
unstimulated blood is shown in gray and
this is the negative control
next we'll shift gears and talk about
extracellular vesicles or evs
evs are membrane-derived structures that
include exosomes microvesicles and
apoptotic bodies
exosomes range from about 30 nanometers
to 100 nanometers
exosomes have been shown to transfer
molecules between cells and have the
potential to transfer signals between
cells
exosomes are released under normal
physiological conditions however
exosomes are also believed to serve as
mediators in the pathogenesis of
neurological vascular hematological and
autoimmune diseases as well as cancer
quantifying and characterizing evs is
challenging due to their small size
high magnification microscopy such as em
can be used to analyze ebs however it's
very low throughput
additionally pmt-based flow cytometers
have a difficult time detecting evs
since they are not highly sensitive
imaging flow cytometers that use a
charge coupled device or ccd camera can
detect ebs such as the cell strain
in order to immunophenotype evs we
follow this workflow using red blood
cells or rbcs and platelet-derived evs
the evs are obtained from solarcus
biosciences the rbcs and platelets were
washed and treated with a calcium
ionophore to induce fasciculation
the vesicles were then isolated via
centrifugation
the resulting evs were labeled with
either an
anti-cd235 antibody with pe
or a cd41 antibody with apc
the labeled ev samples were serial
diluted as shown here
samples were then acquired on the cell
stream for three minutes per sample with
100
laser power
all proper controls were run including
antibody only buffer only and detergent
controls
these controls were run exactly as the
eb samples
samples were run in duplicate on three
cell stream instruments
shown here in the top row is the gating
strategy for identifying the potential
ev populations for both the rbc and
platelet-derived evs
the population ranges from about 50 to
200 nanometers with a peak
around 100 or 120 nanometers with the
platelet evs having a larger tail
the bottom row shows the serial dilution
data the 1 to 60 dilution on the far
left has a significant amount of
coincident events so that concentration
is too high
ev concentration was measured for each
of the dilution controls
these dilution controls were used to
check for swarming
swarming occurs when multiple evs are
detected at once or as a swarm
and not as single objects which is how
we want to detect tvs
as you can see here both sets of
dilutions show a linear decrease in the
potential ep population using the cell
stream for both the pe and the apc
labeled evs
additionally the ev mean intensity was
measured for the dilution controls for
both p e and apc the ev mean intensity
remained consistent for each dilution
the dilution controls shown here
indicate that the potential ev
population consists of single objects
in ev research controls and dilutions
are just as important as your samples
since these help determine what is
artifact or background noise and what is
a true ev
shown here are the data for the pe
positive ev samples and controls and the
corresponding serial dilutions for all
as you can see the average of objects
per microliter for the ev samples are
significantly different from all of the
controls for all dilutions
the low concentration measured for these
background controls validates the ev
population
similar to the pe data the apc positive
evs and corresponding controls show a
significant difference
and therefore the ev population is
validated here as well
since the cell streams has such high
sensitivity and can easily detect evs is
a great system for investigating ev
cargo as well
the data shown here are from a study
investigating evs derived from human
embryonic kidney cells
these evs were stained with the
exagloprotein
and exoglo rna labeling reagents to
detect protein and rna cargo on the ebs
on the left part of this slide
the plots and histograms show the
potential eb population
positive for protein cargo colored in
grain and rna cargo colored in orange
on the top right dilution series data
show that for both protein and rna
positive evs
there is a linear decrease in signal
with extremely low background validating
the labeled ev population
on the bottom right we see stable mean
fluorescence of the positive events for
evs with cargo in the serial dilutions
protein cargo is shown in green and rna
cargo is shown in orange
the same laser intensities were used for
all samples this indicates the
measurement of individual evs and not
swarms of ebs
as you've heard from myself katie and
brian luminex offers a wide range of
flow cytometry products that meet most
research needs as you can see in the
table here we offer a variety of
instruments ranging from our cell
analyzer to our imaging platforms
please contact us with any questions
about our versatile flowcytometers thank
you for listening to our presentation